je suis serveuse d'accord vous êtes
serveuse vous avez combien d'enfants ah
un enfant vous êtes vous occupez de lui
toute seule toute seule aujourd'hui vous
êtes serveuse vous travaillez combien
d'heures par jour
non mais à peu près voilà vous
travaillez minimum 7 heures 7 heures
donc aujourd'hui
avec un enfant vous travaillez elle
travaille elle essaie de faire le
maximum et aujourd'hui vous en sortez
pas non je suis encore chez mes parents
voilà donc parce que vous pouvez pas
aujourd'hui est-ce que je peux pas me
payer un appartement voilà parce que
même de la location moi je suis dans la
banlieue parisienne donc je pense que
vous devez faire j'espère en tout cas
que vous savez le prix d'un loyer moyen
là-bas
HLM étant donné que j'ai fait ma demande
d'HLM enceinte qu'on m'a donné 5 ans
d'attente donc c'est bien une fois qu'il
est à l'école et donc vous Carla parce
que je crois qu'il y a deux problèmes en
fait je pense que il y a surtout le
problème de la retraite mais c'est pas
ça le problème c'est que si les Français
dans la rue aujourd'hui si dans son
français sont dans la rue aujourd'hui
c'est c'est qu'il y a pas que ça c'est
l'accumulation aujourd'hui car là je
suis sûr et certain bien sûr que ça
compte pour elle la réforme de la
retraite mais ce qui compte pour elle
aujourd'hui c'est qu'à l'instant T
aujourd'hui elle s'en sort pas et
qu'elle se dit aujourd'hui j'aimerais
bien qu'on on s'occupe de moi et qu'on
essaie de de m'aider que moi qui
travaille tous les jours je dois m'en
sortir bah c'est ça j'ai 21 ans je suis
seul et je suis chez mes parents voilà
j'ai pas de vie personnelle j'ai pas de
vie privée j'ai rien parce que je veux
Daniel Moreau elle a 80 ans
[Applaudissements]
on en rigole mais je pense que le fond
du problème parce que je vous dis
Shannon je vous jure quand je vous
parlais de timing tout à l'heure je
pense que c'est vraiment et excusez-moi
un Jordan vous y connaissez mieux que
moi et vous aussi Shannon mais je pense
vraiment pour avoir parlé énormément de
français je pense aussi vraiment que
c'est le gros problème c'est à dire que
là il n'aille pas besoin de ça en plus
est-ce que c'est ça car là
en plus pour mon cas à moi qui est le
cas de beaucoup c'est que j'ai pas un
mauvais salaire ben c'est ça
exactement bien payé mais même en étant
bien payé c'est pas possible parce
qu'entre le loyer la voiture l'assurance
les courses si vous avez ne serait-ce
que même l'essence la crèche voilà
exactement ou alors un truc tout bête
mais même inscrire votre fils à la
natation pour qu'il fasse au moins une
activité il sera scolaire mais ça vous
coûte excusez-moi mais une blinde mais
là que deux ans ce que vous me dites je
le mesure je le comprends encore une
fois je suis élu à Rosny-sous-Bois en
Seine-Saint-Denis vous n'êtes pas sans
savoir que un des départements les plus
pauvres de France métropolitaine quand
je vais sur le terrain tous les weekends
et que je vais à la rencontre des
habitants de ma ville et du département
je sillonne le département la
Seine-Saint-Denis je me rends compte je
le vous arrivez à être un problème il y
a un problème de pouvoir d'achat ou le
mesure vous savez vous me parliez Carla
et c'est un témoignage qui touche et qui
touche et je crois qu'on peut tous
s'identifier
oh la pauvre
les problèmes des gens et c'est pour
faire un minimum d'empathie mais vous
oui
c'est que justement on agit car là le
trimestre contient inflation est-ce que
vous avez entendu parler de ce trimestre
anti-inflation
qui vient de démarrer il y a quelques
jours
Bruno Le Maire qui est ministre de
l'économie et des finances
ça ministre délégués laissez-moi finir
monsieur Bardella avec Olivia Grégoire
qui est sa ministre délégué en charge
des petites et des moyens des
entreprises a fait le tour des grands
distributeurs mais le seul la seule
réforme que j'ai entendu moi c'est qu'il
a mis un col roulé qui a donc
donc été faire le tour des opérateurs de
la grande distribution pour négocier
justement une réduction des marges et un
effort laissez-moi finir monsieur
Bardella qui a donc négocié justement
qui est une réduction sur certains prix
du quotidien on fait ce qu'on peut car
là soyez convaincu qu'on fait et vous
voulez on se fait complètement mais vous
savez vous poser une question vous
m'avez dit est-ce que je m'inquiète pour
la retraite de mon fils je m'inquiète
pour la retraite de mon fils mais avant
de m'inquiéter pour ça t'inquiète déjà
pour savoir s'il va manger tu vas avoir
faim toute sa vie
[Applaudissements]
je vous jure que c'est vrai qu'en une
phrase elle a résumé je pense 95% des
Français elle pense à ce qu'elle va
manger demain
quelque chose Monsieur J'ai perdu mon
père il y a 3 ans ma mère se retrouve
seule veuve avec elle est commerçantes
et immigré sur le sol français elle est
commerçante et elle se retrouve tous les
matins elle allait ouvrir son magasin où
elle vend des costumes vous voulez
parler de commerçants de Paris
mais elle tient et elle reconnaît en
tant que combattante
le seul gouvernement qui agit pour
protéger le pouvoir d'achat de nos
concitoyens et nos entreprises avec le
quoi qu'il encourage avec le fond de
solidarité avec des températures c'est
le gouvernement d'Emmanuel Macron je
peux tout entendre je peux tout entendre
je peux entendre vos difficultés mais
cracher sur la politique qui a été celle
de notre gouvernement pendant toutes ces
années pendant le dernier quinquennat
d'Emmanuel Macron avec une banque
on est désormais à moins de 3 millions
de chômeurs sur le sol français 1,2
millions d'emplois qui étaient créés
nous n'avons jamais été aussi des
enfants
vous pouvez pas rentrer là-dedans
le sujet c'est qu'en fait on a le
sentiment qu'on a à la tête du pays des
gens qui n'aiment pas les Français et
que en réalité les gens se disent mais
est-ce que un jour on va avoir à la tête
de l'état des gens qui nous aiment qui
nous respectent qui nous considèrent
parce que quand vous avez un Français
sur deux qui est à 10 euros près quand
il fait ses courses quand vous avez des
gens aujourd'hui qui dans les campagnes
limitent leurs déplacements parce que le
carburant est trop cher pourquoi parce
qu'il y a 60% de taxes sur l'essence que
vous refusez de baisser notamment la TVA
sur les carburants sur l'énergie et bien
les gens se disent mais quand vous
arrivez en face de en leur disant on a
démagogique mais
les gens on se parce qu'en réalité ce
panier anti-inflation c'est rien c'est
du vent vous avez délégué la question du
pouvoir d'achat au
professionnel de l'agroalimentaire le
taux de marge de l'agroalimentaire il
est passé en un an de 30 à 45%
l'agroalimentaire fait des super profits
de dingue et vous refusez les taxer
quand vous achetez je dis aux gens quand
vous achetez un bidon de lessive arrière
à 12 euros vous avez 3 euros qui partent
immédiatement dans les supers profits et
qui vont engraisser les actionnaires ce
sont des super profits indus il faudra
les taxer plutôt que de taxer toujours
les mêmes mais il y a beaucoup de gens
et notamment les classes populaires les
classes moyennes qui bossent qui ont le
sentiment qu'on tape toujours sur eux
que c'est toujours à eux qu'on demande
des comptes et que ce sont toujours eux
qui doivent payer pour le reste de la
société
mais il y a des propositions on verra ça
après on est pas dans un débat politique
là s'il vous plait juste
qui était pour la réforme des retraites
et un lapin lapin qui était
en fait je comprends pas pourquoi on
travaille moins que globalement dans
tous les autres pays européens en France
bah partout en fait en Italie entre en
Italie on prend la retraite beaucoup
plus tard il me semble et en Allemagne
c'est vrai vous avez raison et en
Allemagne il y a deux fois plus de
retraités pauvres